Yle Areena.
[Musiikkia]
No niin, jääkiekkofani, hei! Kuulepas, miten ihmeellä myös saadaan ne Suomen jääkiekkopojat laulamaan se maamme laulu, kun ne on voittanut peliin?
Siis kaikki on toppisuuna siellä. Kyllä se nyt ois aika iso kunnia Suomellekin, että ne osais laulaa sen maamme laulun. Ois se niin hienoa. Kiitos, hei!
No täältä Itä Suomesta. Katselin tuossa jääkiekkopelia ja kaikkea muita juhlita, mutta se suurin joka sen Suomen kultamikalin on voittanut, niin se on maaliva. Kunnia hänelle, kiitos.
Miesten jääkiekon MM-finaalin aikana meidän automaattinen vastaaja sai kyllä hyvin ansaitun lepohetken, niin vähäistä viestien määrää en itse muista nähneeni tai kuuleeni koskaan aikaisemmin. Eipä tuo mikään yllätys, kun koko kansan katseet ja keskittyminen oli suunnattu jonkun kokoiselle ruudulle tai kankaalle. Se on Kansan Radio ja Lasse Olkinuora tässä tervehdys. Eipä tuo keränyt kumminkaan ihan liian pitkään pölyä keräämään meidän vastaaja aika nopeasti.
Se nopeasti tapahtui paluun normaaliin ottelun jälkeen. Ja mistä aiheesta niitä viestejä on taas tullut? No hyvin monenlaisesta. Voiko olla niin, että Suomessa joku ei osaa keittää perunoita? Ja voiko olla niin, että mies haluaa parisuhteeseen vain saadakseen itselleen palvelijan? Ja pitäisikö kaikki kansanedustajat laittaa maalle asumaan, niin ymmärtäisivät asioita vähän paremmin. Koulun päättäjäiset, myös siihen liittyviä aiheita on kommentoitu.
Tässä vakava varoitus Kansan Radion kuuntelijoille. Huumeet väkivalta, rikollisuus. Niistä yhteiskunta selviää aivan käden käänteessä, mutta varokaa Suvivirttä. Se voi viedä ihmisen huonoille teille jo muutamassa hetkessä. Tämä oli varoitus. Kiitos.
Miksei sitä voi koulus soittaa? Olen 7.6. Olen aloittanut koulun vuonna 56, 57. Syksyllä ja kyllä aina joka jumalankevää kun tuli Suvivirse, niin se oli se merkki, että alkoi kesäloma. Tätä en käsitä. Mikä siinä on niin äärimmäisen vaikeaa, että ei voi Suvivirttä laulaa?
Kyllä jos tämä uskontoa jotenkin liittyy. Se on virsikirjassa tiedän, mutta en ota sitä millään tavalla virreksi. Hyvää päivänjatkoa kaikille.
Iltainen vastattelussa perheen isä nollasi itsensä täysin Ville Rydmanin edessä. Olen kenelle kokoomuslainen enkä perso. Jos Jeesusta ei Jumala jossain vilahtaa, ei Espoon kaupungin pidä missään nimessä mitään sakkoja maksaa. Tämä touhu on lähtenyt käsistä niin kuin koiran kakkakeskustelu keväisin. Suvivirsi on aina laulettu kevätjuhlassa ja lauletaan edelleen. Että sille.
Tuossa katselen tätä pelevisio-meiminkiä juuri kun on tätä KUV lopettamisviikon loppu. Se on rankkaa monelle. Se on rankka ryyppyjuhla. Poliisi voimaton kaikki jo tosin on niin kuin valmiina että on täällä nykymaailma ihan. Siis johon verran kun ajattelin että 40-luvulla, 40-luvulla olisiko me noin yhti? Ei helvetti. Porukat kokoontuu oikein ison laumo ja siellä ryypätään.
Että on alaikäinen tai vähän yleikäinen mutta pitää juoda kun koulu loppuu ja sitten ne toiset juhlat sitten kun koulu alkaa. Ei voi muuta kuin ihmetellä perkeleen nykyään lapsi ja nuori.
Marjatta on laittanut meille viestin WhatsAppin välityksellä. Kirjoittaa että ihanaa miten hyvin asiat Suomessa onkaan niin hyvin että meillä aikuisilla on aikaa riidellä siitä että mitä lauletaan koulujen kevätjuhlissa. Ja kansanedustajillakin on aikaa käydä televisiossa laulamassa suvivirttä. Hyvä Suomi ja huutomerkkiin päättää viestinsä Marjatta. Mitä muuta televisiosta nähty ja radiosta kuultu niin sitähän me kuulemme.
Tässä on seuraavaksi. Kaisa on radionsoitittu. Pyydän armoa. Armoa semmoista asiaa että saataisiinko nyt jotain järkeä tähän että kun MTV kolmoselta tulee ruokaohjeita niin luuleeko ne aivan oikeasti että suomalainen nainen ja mies kun se laittaa ruokaa se on idiookki. Hyvänen aika. Annetaan Perunan kenellä.
Keitto ohjeita eikö jokainen meistä osaa keittää perunoita. Tämä koski uusia perunoita kun oli yhtenä päivänä. Ja sitten se että jos nyt joskus ihmiseltä tulee semmoinen lämpsäys että sieltä osakkaat niin paneet ereksissä kylmään veteen uudet perunat kaataako se tämän maan. Heidän mielestään se kaataan. On aivan käsittämätöntä tämmöinen toulu.
Ja sitten raparperistä oli perjantaina. Kuka tekee raparperin lehdestä raparperipirkkaa? Älyhoi! Kiellettiin semmoinen. Eihän se nyt ole mahdollista.
Ja sitten vielä yksi asia tästä ruuanlaitosta. Mitä varten sinä päivänä kun on joku juhlapäivä annetaan ruokaohje tai joku tarjoiluohje. Äitien päivänä annettiin että tällaista voi tehdä äitien päivänä. No lähde nyt kesken äitien päiväonnittelujen kauppaan juoksemaan ja hakemaan tavaraa että sinä pystyt tämmöisen herkun tekemään äidille. Tällaisia asioita.
Hyvä juttu kun soitit minä kiitän tästä ja hyvät sunnut sitä samaa. Kiitos. Hei hei hei.
Tässä on niin tekonauru. Eiks tää vois yhtään hillitä varsinkin tää naistoime Kamalaan käkätys. Nämä radion toivekonsertit. Metsärario ei järvirario ja tää puhelintoivekonsertti voi yleensä huomioida. Kyllä se on oikein Kamala mitä monessa muskipaikassa se käkättäminen on riessä.
Tuossa naapurinkaupungista ja törkein hyvä tyyppi tää olavi virta. On kuulu hänen musiikkia yle eturahaskanavalta yli ysineroiselta ja ilta oli mulle vähän uustuttavuus ei huono. Kuusi virta ottaa kyllä yleensä ja ylelle tuhat pistettää ei muuta. Moikka.
Yhdeksäs päivä perjantaina kun Arttu vain kiiroili laulussa. Miksi Yle antaa tulla tämmösiä ohjelmia kun siellä oli paljon lapsiakin kuulumassa. Ois kyllä parannut sen paikka. Karso-Janna ei kiro saa pois. Kiitos.
Arvoisa puhemies Arto Joones Posta. Olen eläkkeellä oleva sairaanhoitaja ja valmistuin Helsingin sairaanhoito-opistosta tuhat yhdeksänsataakuuskymmentäviisi. Ja sinne pyrkiessä kävin läpi tiukat todella tiukat kaksipäiväiset asiantuntijoitten laativat ja paikalla olevat soveltuvuustestit valituksi tulemiseen. Niin ihmettelen nykyään. Tulevatko nykyään työpaikoja?.
Nykyiset hoitajat suoraa kadulta kouluun ja töihin. Onko alalle sopivuudella enää yhtään mitään väliä?. Tämä alue esimerkiksi Aastudion keskustelussa viime viikolla jäi kovin sivuun. Kielitaitoa painotetaan, mutta siis nyt nykyisistä toimintatavoista nähdään, että soveltuvuus on varmaan kovin sivuasiassa.
Elikkä tätä ajattelen ja ihmettelen useasti. Niin sellaisia kysymyksiä eli pitäisi palata vähän edeltävän kaltaisiin. Kyllä liian lujaa mennään eteenpäin ja tosiaan puhutaan vain kielitaidosta, mutta siis tämä soveltuvuus on ihan kaiken perustajapohja. Muuten mennään ihan päin seinää totaalisesti. Joo, elikkä näin.
Mikä rupesi kiinnostamaan se soveltuvuuskoe tai kokeet, mitkä itse olet käynyt läpi? Jääkö siitä jotain erityisesti mieleen joku erityisen?. Siis siitä on kauan aikaa, mutta sen muistan, että ne olivat tosi tiiviit. Ihan siis kaksipäiväiset kokopäiväiset. Okei, joo. Siinä ei paljon hengitystaukoja anneta?. Ei, ei. Ja muualta päin Suomea tulin pyrkimään eli piti tulla pääkaupunkiseksi.
Piti pääkaupunkiseudulle sitä varten päästäkseni sisään ja pääsin ja hakijoita oli muistaakseni sata määrin eikä meitä otettukaan kuin kaksiluokalleista noin viisikymmentä. Elikkä siitäkin näkee, että tiukassa oli. Mikä muuten oli sitten ensimmäinen työpaikka?. Se oli Tilkan sairaala. Tilkan sairaala. Okei, no niin just näin, että tähän alueeseen pitäisi nyt kiivaasti kiinnittää huomiota enemmän.
- Minä kiitä, että sinä soitit. - Kiitos, kiitos samoin kuulemisesta, hei. - Päivän jatkot. - Kiitos samoin. - Paikallisraporttia on meille nyt seuraavaksi luvassa ja Lappeen ranta on meidän ensimmäinen kohde, kunhan ensiksi tämä yksi viesti saapunut meille Pieksämäeltä. Iltapäivälehdessä kerrottiin naisesta, joka halusi isomman takapuolen ja hankki suurennuksen Brasiliassa. Kateutta kai, mutta olkoon kun äimistyin kovasti. Ajattelin,
Teko ihminen siis tässä tapauksessa alle kolmekymppinen että miltä ne pyllykät näyttävät kun ikää tulee lähes puolet enemmän. Vai onko ne sulaneet teille tietymättömillä? Hän ei nähnyt mitään kummallista leikkauksessa paitsi kuulemma istua ei voinut. No minulla on ehdotus tekopylly siis silikoonista tai vastaavasta tehty pöksyihin kiinnitetty tarroilla olisi huomattavasti terveellisempi ja halvempi vaihtoehto. Se sopisi myös kaiken ikäisille ja itse tuntokin nousee
Kohisteen. Tällaisen viestin allekirjoittanut nimimerkki Litta Pylly -Kesät Talvet Pieksemäki.
Olette jo saaneet keskustankin autioksi, ei ihmisiä on kun Itä-Saksa koko keskusta ja nyt tullaatte jo satamankin, ravintoloita ja juottoloita pilvin pimein kaupungissamme ja tuota kaikkia sitten rantaraitille jotakin betoniseiniä pitää hyviksi rakentaa sinne ja asurakennuksia kylpylaitoksen rannat täyteen ja pilata kauniista rantaa Kulevardi Kulevardi tuota tätä kylätyöstä.
Täältä on niin paljon vanhoja rakennuksia hävitetty ja tuo torikki mikä oli ennen satamassa sinne niin tuota se on pilattu tyystin viety tuonne keskustalle koko torihomma ja laivoja on mutta taivolakaan ei suurelle Saimaalle pääse tuota ja on kalja ja juottola näidenne satamassa ja Savonlinna kun vedottuna siellä on laivoja lähisvaaristoista risteillä niin tää on niin uinunut. Tää on kun Itä-Saksa tää koko keskusta on tuhottu kaupat tyhjittävät.
Niin ei ihmisiä niin kuin kourallinen keskenään päivään ja iltapäivään oikein ollenkaan ei muuta. Ei muuta. Heippa!
Niin kuin noin kauppausten kalamien niitten pitää aina tuota niin tossa äänisäädessä niin pitää sitten tuota niin noin niin kuin säädellä aina. Ne pitää olla niin kuin samalla tasolla. Kiitos! Heppa!
Ne pitää niin kuin rakentaa uudelleen niistä jotakin semmoista hyödyllistä. Vaikka Legotalo. Kiitos! Modobobobobobobobobobobo.
vanhuksesta. Kaupunkiinkin voi tehdä tämmöisiä rakenteellisia asioita että ne nostavat vuokratasoa niin kuin vuokra asunnoissa Helsingin kaupungilla ja sitten samalla tontiin vuokrat niin kuin ne nousevat aina indeksin mukaan. Mutta milloin sitten huomioidaan sitten se asia kuin mikä tämä yhteiskunnallinen tilanne on sitten kuitenkin että eihän nyt asuntoihin jotka vihan loputtomia voivat nostaa. Tätä halusin vaan kysyä sitä kyseenalaista nyt että en ole ihan tyytyväinen tämmöiseen toimintaan kuitenkaan että ei muuta kuin päivän jatkeet.
Kansanradio. No niin Timppa Liedossa. Moro. Minun täytyy tämmöisestä sulle tai Suomen kansalle lähdimme ihmetellä kevyen liikenteen, varsinkin polkupyöräilijät. Se on minulle sydämen tykytyksen asia. Onko tämä nimenomaan Liedossa? No ei vaan Turussa lähinnä. Minä pyöriin ja raisiosaan ja sitten tuolla antamme lisää. Tällainen juttu kun minä aion tämmöisellä isommalla autolla sata sata sata viisi kilometriä päivätä.
Minä en ymmärrä tätä asiaa kun ei katsella yhtään niin kuin että pää on alhaalla ja sitten luulen että kun tullaan risteyksien yli niin se on niin kuin tavako siinä on niin kuin suojatie mutta kun Turun saakka ei ole jokaisen suojatiellä edes pyörätien jatkoa niin liikennemerkit eivät aina lupaa siitä syheltää täysillä polkupyörällä. Siinä tulee semmoisia kattoja alueita tiedätkö sinä ettei sitä aina näe edes vaikka koita. Siis koita on varaa.
Totta kai eihän kukaan kenenkään päälle halua ajaa. No niin ei kyllä. Niin mutta minullakin on käyty siis kymmeniä kymmeniä kymmeniä kertoja että joku nostaa keskisormensa siinä ja kun minä saan juuri pysähtynyt niin kuin että kirkkahtelee jarrut ja jokaisen pitäisi ymmärtää kuin sinä käy vaikka olis kuin oikeassa itse. Jos toinen ei sua näe siinä niin voisi aina jokainen kattoa niin kuin ennen opetettiin ettei.
Ihan pitäisi kattoa vaikka on vaikka on etua jo oikeus niin silti hyvä vähän vilkuilla ympärilleen. Niin koska eihän minulle siellä hytissä mitään käy mutta sille toiselle käy siinä aika huonosti. No se on totta. Tavallaan niin kuin yleinen semmoinen liikenne kulttuurin heikkeneen harmittaa. Okei. Ihan ihan yleisestikin autojen kanssa tai autoliikenteestä niin niin niin niin.
Tämmöinen viittaamattomuus ja ja ja ohituksien ohituksien niin kuin suorittaminen ihan täysin niin kuin semmoisella tilanteessa missä et voi nähdä millään mitä sen jonkun nyppylän niin kuin takaa tulee niin sehän on ihan ihan yleistä. Se on semmoinen semmoinen tän päivän kun vähän tää kulttuuri että että minulle kaikki heti tänne. Minä katselen omiakin omiakin jälkijälkipolvia.
Niin niin niin. Niillä on semmoinen sukkela sukkela taas ennenpäin se on hiukan niin joo eli siis kansanradion välityksellä kaikille pyöräilijöille ja myös miksei muillekin että liikenteessä muistakaa nyt se että siellä on muitakin. Nimenomaan siis tähän on yhteispeliä. Tähän on yhteispeliä. Muuten se ei pel... muuten se ei toimi että se täytyisi opetella jokaisen semmoisen perus perus niin kuin liikennettään. Minä kiitän kun soitit.
Minä kiitän myös sinua. Minä kiitän sinua. Niin no niin hei mitä päivänjakot. Moro moro. Reaktioita viime viikon jaksoon kuullaan seuraavaksi sitä ennen yksi reaktio viime viikolla järjestettyihin leijonien kultajuhlaan. Eikö mikään riitä. Hyvää leijonat kiitos teidän. Mutta ihmeellistä nämä valittajat ja kitisiät. Ettekö ymmärrä mitä ja miten nopeasti kaikki järjestyi teille ja ilmaiseksi. Jokainen kulttuuri.
Niin mitä niiden kitisiä voisi minun mielestä laittaa vaikka lastensairaalalle festarilipun hinnan verran lahjoitusta. Ilon ja riemun juhla jossa yläkerran herrakin oli mukana antaen kauniin sään. Niin mitä siitä oikein puuttui kun arvostelu tuntuu olevan tärkeintä.
Joo, päivää. Soittelen semmoista, kun joku vanhempi nainen siellä kysyi, että miehet eivät pärjää lainkaan yksin, että ne syyttävät naisia jostain asioista. Mutta onkohan se näin, että voiko sitä yleistää yleensäkään, että yhdellä lauseella, että...
No pitääkö se sinun mielestä paikkaansa?
Ei se oikeestaa. Siinä on myös semmoista, että onko nainen sinut kehonsa kanssa. Ja siinä on montaa monessa. Miksi naiset sitten välttelee miestä?
Mitä sanoit, että ettei ole sinut kehonsa kanssa?
Puhun nyt hormonaalaisista jutuista. Sinun on montaa monessa, niin kuin näissä aina. Onko tyytyväinen itseensä?
Ja se tyytymättömyys itseensä sitten tulee siis sillä tavalla, ettei halua ketään lähelle. Ja okei.
Ei enää, jos ei näitä ole selvitellyt. Siis kumpika mieskää myös siinä. - Paljon ja isoja kysymyksiä. - On joo, että ei se aina yksin suuntaista. - Niin, eikä asiat harvemmin on mustavalkoisia. - Joo. Eipä tässä muuta tälle hava. - Hei, minä kiitän kun soitit. Mainita. Kiitos, moi. - Moi.
- Porista, hei. Joku kertoi, että miehet eivät yksin ole, että ne tarvitsevät aina jonkun passaajan. Ja tähän asiaan minun on semmoinen, että minä itse asuin. Seurustelin Turussa turkulaisen miehen kanssa. Ja hän esitteli minun sukulaisilleni. Tässä on hänen uusi taloudenhoitaja. Kaiken kaikkiaan oltiin neljä ja puoli vuotta. Ja sitten minä kyllästyin taloudenhoitajahommiin.
Lähdin Poriin takaisin ja kolme viikkoa siitä oli joust taloudenhoitaja. Kyllä se näin on, että miehet eivät yksin halua olla. Ne tarvitsevat aina jonkun taloudenhoitajan sinne. Näin se vaan on.
Niin kun kai se oli neljäkymmentä lukua, niin sai ensimmäisen kansan eläkeen. Ja kun hän tuli sieltä kyljiltä, niin sanoi, että kyllä nyt pidetään vaan noissa aiheistakin hyvä uoli. Tyytyväisyyttä, tyytyväisyyttä vaan ja ollut toivoitus syntyä Suomeen. No niin, heippa.
Minä olen jyrkästi samaa mieltä ja olen tätä jo ihmetellyt vuosikymmeniä ja harmitellut ja yrittänyt kantaa Kortenin kekoon asian korjaamiseksi. Ja minulla on nyt tämmöinen vahva idea, että myös maahanmuuttajille nämä suomalaiset perinne laulut, siis lähinnä tietysti lapsille koulun myötä olisi erittäin tärkeätä, että pääsisimme sisään tähän suomalaiseen kulttuuriin ja sielunmaisemaan. Tietysti sielunmaisema on nyt eri kuin mitä täällä on.
se on ollut siihen aikaan kun nämä perinnelaut oli voimissaan, mutta minusta se sielu oli aika hieno ja se sielunmaisema oli niin hieno, että siitä ei kannattaisi luopua vaan sitä kannattaisi pitää yllä ja kannustaa sitä ja esitellä sitä myös niille jotka tulevat tänne asumaan meidän maahan ja he voisivat osallistua paitsi laulamalla myös voitaisiin soittaa ja tehdä niistä mielenkiintoisia sovituksia ja vaittaa niihin ryhmäjään.
elementtejä heidän omista kulttuureistaan ja tanssiminenkin voisi olla sallittua. Tämmöinen ajatus ja toive ja olen mielelläni osallistumassa tässä toteuttamisessa sikäli kun tämmöstä saadaan aikaan. Kiitos Eiju.
Turussa mummo on kirjoittanut kirjeen ja lähettänyt sen sitten meille tänne Kansanradioon. Pahoittelee aluksi että kirjoittaa käsin mutta kun ei käytä näitä nykyajan vempeleitä paitsi sitä kännykkää on pakko joskus käyttää. Tässä yksikseni olen miettinyt noita hallituksen ja kansanedustajien toimia. Varsinkin meidän ministerit eivät tiedä tavallisen ihmisen elämästä yhtään mitään. Olisiko syytä laittaa jokainen elämään toimeentulo tai työttömyystuella?
Osatyöaikapalkalla tuhannen kahdensadan euron eläkkeellä tai vastaavalla vähintään esimerkiksi puoli vuotta. Mahtaisivatko heidän silmänsä avautua? Toiseksi puoleksi vuodeksi voisivat mennä töihin, vanhainkoteihin, sairaanhoitajiksi, opettajiksi, lastentarhoihin tai kaupankassoille tavallisiin töihin niillä palkoilla. Myös maanviljelijänä ja karjankasvattajana heidän olisi hyvä hetki olla.
Näitä asioita siis tuumii Turun mummo. Jaa Saarijärvelta Paavo Vaansoittelee, hyvää päivää. Älkää Haina, hyvät ihmiset, moittikot. Hallitustani tuosta työttömyydestä eihän se voi mitään työpaikkoja. Ei silloin mitään työpaikkoja antaa. Kun on tämmöinen melkein koko Eurooppaa koskeva matalapaine ja hyvät eivät ole laman kourissa, niin ei se voi hallituksessa.
Ei tule yhtään mitään sille, että SDP varsinkin ja vasemmisto jatkuvasti jankuttaa samaa asiaa, että nuorille töitä. Mutta minäkin olen ollut kuuskymmentä vuotta yrittäjän, että yrittäisin itsekin jotain järkeellä omaa yritystä. Ja silloin ei kaikkia lasketa hallituksen viakosta. Hallitus on erittäin hyvä ollut ja tehnyt hyviä asioita tähän mennessä. Ei tässä muuta, mutta halloja odotellessa. Kiitos ja moi.
Kiekko kuuskasi tässä soittelee. Haukkuvat hallitusta kaikin tavoin, mutta työllisyys paranee. Teollisuus elpyy. Tuotanto elpyy. Maamiinat on tullut takaisin. Suota ruvetaan uudestaan käyttämään ja kaiken kukkuraksi Suomi voitti maailmanmestrouden. Voiko tätä hallitusta kukaan moittia? Se on kyllä turhaa touhunta.
ja yritystä. Jos tämä hallitus saa jatkaa niin sieltä tulee ihmeellisiä oittoja Suomi nousuun. Suomi nousuun. - No tieltä pohjoisavusta tulta kuuskymmeneen.
Ei ole semmoinen ehdotus kun meillä kansanedustajillekään on ne avustajat niin laittaisivat kun on ensin lukko ne tekstit ja muuten valmistellu niin ne avustajat sinne kansanedustajin penkille ja kansanedustajat.
Asumaan tänne muodot tulta missä ei ole hyvinkään sata kilometriä olempiin palveluihin ja saadaanloihin matko tulta ja olisi kantoo, veitti ja puut niin voisivat tulta yhden talven vaikka kuukauden kaks asuisivat semmoisissa pikkusen vaatimattomissa oloissa ja tulta nii ruppaisivat sitten ehden tietämättä miten se on tällä muodolla asuminen ja tulta tarvisteeko ne nuo vanahukset tulta mitä apuja on vaan eikö ja sitten voisivat vaikka vähän silmätä.
Ei voi millä tulta maatallota että minkälaisia laskoja niille maatallois yrittäjille tullo ja mitä kaikkea joutuu tekemään. Tietysti isot on pallot ja konnet mut kyllä niillä on velkoita. Pitäis Pekkuso ajatella noitakin maatallois yrittäjiltä. Me emme kyllä ihan leppälle lagerilla. Eipä tässä muuta kuin syvää kevää alku.
Olen puolestaan odottaa että mihin numeroon tai osoitteeseen voi kommentoida vaikkapa nyt sitten tässä lähetyksessä kuultua asiaa niin nyt niitä tulee. Meidän WhatsApp numero se on 044 5515464. Siihen voi laittaa viestiä tekstitse tai äänitse. Sähköpostiosoite tänne se on kansan.radio.yle.fi ja kirjetta tai korttia jos haluaa lähettää niin.
Kansan.radio pl 7 yhdeksän nolla nolla nolla kaksi neljä yleisradio. Niin ja tietysti tuo meidän vastaaja. Sehän meinasin jäädä 0 8 nolla nolla yksi viisi neljä kuusi neljä ja sunnuntaina sitten lähetyksen jälkeen ihmis vastaaja on paikalla kolmen tunnin ajan ottamassa vastaan juuri sinun puhelun. Mutta nyt on aika Lasse Olkinuoran kiittää. Kiitos kun olit seuraava.
Kiitos paljon jos laitoit meille tänne viestiä. Minä itse rupean nyt tässä pikkuhiljaa jo odottelemaan että milloin lähitorille ilmestyvät kotimaiset herneet. Mutta sehän se on tässä Suomen kesässä paras puoli että ei ole niin kiire asioiden kanssa kun tämä kesä itsessään jo tuo niin paljon hyvää mieltä ja iloa. Minä toivotan oikein hyvää päivänjatkoa. Hyvästi keuruulta päivää. Minua ihmetyttää tämä armeijan miestä.
Sitten väsymys. Ne saavat palkkaa. Ei niillä ole huono palkka ja kaikki muutenkin. Ja tuota sitten tämä näin että kun pojat menee armeijaan kun minä olin armeijassa niin se oli kunnia asia meille. Tämä palvelus suoritetaan eikä tulla maitojunalla takaisin. Nyt minä kohta puolet tulee maitojunalla kun ei ne jaksa tehdä mitään. Aivan älytöntä. Sitten minä tästä asiasta minä niin kuin.
Syyttäisin vanhempia. Vanhemmat ovat mitättömiä kasvattamaan lapsia, koska niissä pitäisi tehdä isänmaallisia ja kunnon kansalaisia. Tätä ei ole. Ne oikein nyt häkkänä sanovat, että väsyvät. Miten sinne voi väsyä, kun saa vielä kunnon palkan? Kiitos kaikesta. Hei.
Että nosti postimerkkeen hintaa ihan tuosta vaan yksi kaksi. Aamulla vaan oli netissä, että näin on käynyt. Eilen ei tiedetty asiasta mitään. Nostetaan kun pensahinta. Näinkö ne kirjepostit sitten lisääntyvät kun nostetaan hintaa koko ajan ja siellä vaan sählätään näitten haltispakettien kanssa? Että kattokaa vähän mikä on teidän oikea homma. Ei muuta kuin kesänjatkoja. Moi.
Hei. Olisin semmosta asiaa sanonut, kun nykyisin kaupasta saa tätä niin sanottua ruisleipää, joka ei ole ruisleipää vaan se on mallasleipää. Toivoisin, että leipurit leipoisivat ihan kunnon ruisleipää. Ja toinen asia. Miksi meille juotetaan tänä päivänä kahvia, vaikka se ei kahville maistukkaan? Kiitos.
kansalaisille vauvasta vaariin niin hyvää Suomen kesää. Tämmöinen viesti: - Onko maailmassa paljon parempaa asiaa kuin Suomen kesä? - Älä muuta sanoa. Ja sitten toi on rikkaus Suomessa kun täällä on neljä vuoden aikaa. Joka paikassahan sitä ei ole. Ohjoismaissa on se neljä vuoden aikaa. - Kyllä vain. Myös myöhäissyksy ja räntäsateet on rikkaus koska se saa ihmisen arvostamaan.
kaikkea muuta todella paljon. - Se on ihan totta. Minä olen tosta aselta sun kanssa ihan samaa mieltä. On rikkaus, todella rikkaus neljä vuoden aikaa kunnalle. - Näin on. En kyllä haluaisi siitä luopua. - En minäkään. Mutta hei kuule, hyvää sunnuntapäivää sinulle ja palaillaan taas. - Näin me tehdään. Päivän jatkut. - Pärjääileä.